retreated that's uh i'm kind of like
that idea yeah there's lots of choice
from okay he is about to move his knight
in the middle of the board he's not on
the d two square he's gonna bring it to
the left he's gonna bring it forward and
try to put pressure on black's central
pawn but no okay he's just clicked off
that move so a bit of indecisiveness
from the world champion for sure he's
not in his opening preparation anymore
now he's about to push his corner pawn
forward that's another trademark move
from magnus and he's clicked off that
one as well
that sounds kind of dangerous though to
like because suddenly you lose the piece
right i've done that before actually you
know i've gone i've thought about making
a move i've hovered over the square i've
even clicked the piece and then
now i've kind of changed my mind and
then before you know it the piece is
actually returned to a different square
and i'm like no i did not want to play
that in fact that's something that
magnus did himself yeah um he lost the
game against i want to say levon
was it
i just remember it was it was something
that was a queen
it
it was a strange queen move and also the
first game of the whole tour this season
magnus mouse slipped right right he
tried to give check with his queen and
he dropped the queen on the wrong square
uh where she was vulnerable where she
was about to get captured and he had to
resign against nobody actually so
especially with long range pieces like
queens and rooks that's where the mouse
lips actually usually occur because they
you have to drag them often five six
squares and you might drop them along
the way or you might drop them on the
way back if you change your mind yeah so
it's the long-range pieces that's where
you're vulnerable with mouse clips
should it be like a button where you
have to confirm your move or is it you
can't have that button okay it does slow
you down yeah
when you're under 30 seconds you don't
want to have to click an extra time
every time you make a move
so they they decide to not have it these
players yes by default you're expected
not to have it but you can add it and go
into the settings okay so magnus decides
to initiate action on the left side of
the board